hello everyone if I had to describe the
Boris Spassky with one word I would
definitely describe him as a gentleman
when Boris Spassky won his championship
title against Tigran Petrosian the first
the first thing he did was went and
prolonged the the registration on his
car there's a story about Fischer and
Spassky they were playing in a
tournament when they were still young
and the Bobby was very shy and the the
first half of the tournament
Bobby's score wasn't very good and he
was somewhere at the half of the
tournament table so Boris Spassky
knocked on his door and he invited him
to go for a walk and to you know go see
the bar and they had a very nice evening
and for the rest of the tournament Bobby
played spectacularly and Boris Spassky
won first place and Bobby Fischer
finished second so in a lot of ways
Boris Spassky is responsible for you
know making Fischer a bit more normal
than he was and this I'm about to show
you was played in Mar del Plata
Argentina in 1960 at the time this game
was played Boris Spassky and Bobby
Fischer were the two youngest
grandmasters in the world and this is
their first encounter so Boris Spassky
is white and Bobby Fischer is black spot
he plays efore Bobby plays d5 and now to
everyone's amazement Boris Spassky
played step for the Kings gambit and of
course Fischer accepts the challenge and
he plays he takes on f4 we have Knight
to f3 g 5h for G for Knights to e5
Knight to f6 v for d6 kicking the knight
Knight goes to b3 Knight captures on e4
Bishop captures on f4 Bishop g7 Knight
to c3 Knight captures on c3 big casters
on c3 c5 Bishop to e2 c takes on d4 and
Spassky castles here
Fisher plays Knight to c6 Bishop
captures in G for Spock Fisher castles
Bishop captures on c8 ro captures on c8
and although black's pawn structure is
somewhat messed up he is a pawn up and
this position is completely fine for
black so Fisher is even better here we
have twin to g4 with pinning the Bishop
f5 Queen to g36 captures another pawn
here rook to e1 came to h8 unpinning
King to h1 Rock the g8 Bishop captures
on d6 Bishop to f8 Bishop to e5 check
picture captures the bishop and I'd take
75 Queen takes on e5 would check rook
the g7 rook captures on f5 Queen to h4
check King to g1 Queen to g4 threatening
checkmate on G - we have rook to F -
Bishop to e7 rook to e4 attacking the
Queen Queen to g5 wheat to d4 Spassky
doesn't want to exchange Queens and if
you look at this position this is a well
it's maybe a bit easier to play this for
white but black is still actually better
in this position and if you ask the
engine Bobby it was better for the
entire game
and in this position Bobby should have
played something like roof to d8 this
seems well it seems like a human move
and it seems like a very strong move
because if you look at the position this
knife is well placed but he can never
move as this Bishop to c5 move will be
deadly for black for white so instead of
this rook to d8 Bobby Fischer blunders
and he plays rook to f8 and he misses a1
very well decisive tactic by Spassky
here's Part C plays rook to e5 attacking
the Queen and now you see this Queen
doesn't really have a good place
go if she goes on h4 for example to
still protect this bishop and if if the
queen is captured then Bishop Annette
catches on h4 then this rook is hanging
so rope casters on a faith which check
and after rook e5 Fisher tried roof to
d8 so he plays the move that she should
have played one move ago but this now
completely allows the tactic Spassky
plays queen three four and now you see
this Bishop is attacked so we have Queen
to h4 and Spassky plays rook to f4
and in this position official resigns as
well there's no move for him to play
whatever he plays as possible just
capture the bishop on e7 and it's all
over
so yeah this was the the first encounter
of Bobby Fischer and Boris Spassky and
it's a nice thing to see that Spassky
won their first encounter even though
Bobby will win their last official
encounter and just illustrate how strong
these guys were Boris Spassky finished
first in this tournament and Bobby
Fischer finished second but both of them
had 13 and a half points Spassky was
first because he won in their you know
in their encounter and third was done
with Bronstein who was two points behind
them so naturally there were two of the
youngest grandmasters in the world and
well this tournament in Mar del Plata
Argentina had a lot of press coverage so
yeah I hope you enjoyed this game and if
you're interested here are my two
previous games that I recorded some time
ago I'm pretty sure we haven't seen them
one is about the first world champion
Wilhelm Steines and the other one is
well a story about a young boy who just
wanted to play chess featuring nickel
cheering I hope you check those out and
if you do you know feel free to comment
on them and
I will see you soon